on sort je pense que ce serait bien que
les français épargnent pas simplement à
la gauche mais c'est par nous mêmes et
c'est par nos pays un nouveau 21-avril
surtout qu' il n'est pas dit que ce set
nous ce nouveau botté avril soit le même
média en avril d'un certain point de vue
ça commence mal et ça finit bien
si j'ose dire le premier tour comme à la
maison mais tout est à des ares 2e tour
le premier tour est le premier tour est
un désastre deuxième tour se finit par
la victoire de jacques chirac à laquelle
j'aime aussi contribuer à plus de 80% de
la pub 80 % des voix euh là les risques
sont différents
françois fillon n'est pas jacques chirac
d'eni dans son programme ni dans son
identité ni dans la partie de la droite
avec lequel ils se rattachent non à
droite qui le porte et il m'a écouté là
on a beaucoup de diaboliser dans le
passé jacques chirac c'est ce que vous
faites aujourd'hui avec françois fillon
n'ont coûté jacques chirac a toujours eu
ce nom je crois que c'est pas deux
personnalités identique
j'ai pas souvenir qu'on est en moi je me
souviens de quelques petites phrases de
jacques chirac
souvenez vous il y avait fait chaud
chirac je serai une petite phrase de
jacques chirac
mais en 2002 on met dans une situation
connaît déjà
on a vu chirac déjà présent de la
république
on sait que jacques chirac est somme
toute dans une espèce de tradition d'une
droite qui continue de s'inspirer du
compromis gaulliste voilà pour la fusion
c'est différent parce que s'ils
s'obstinent à faire la campagne qu'il a
fait dans l'imprimé à dire ce qu'il dit
en particulier en 15 de modèle social
s'ils s'obstinent à vouloir être le
margaret thatcher de la france un
certain point de vue et à être aussi le
conservateur parmi les conservateurs
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils créent les
conditions pour que le deuxième tour en
2017 soit aussi facile que l'a été celui
de jacques chirac
mais là vous verrez du principe déjà que
la gauche était lumineux 90 après je
continue et dans l'hypothèse où c'est la
gauche qui est devant qui est face à
marine le pen au deuxième tour
je ne suis pas sûr non plus que le
discours de la droite d'aujourd'hui
favorise rassemblement républicain au
deuxième tour contre marine le pen
donc je ne vois qu'une solution pour
nous prémunir de marine le pen en 2017
c'est un deuxième tour droite gauche